وبما اننا نشهد موسم كاس العالم هذه
الايام نشاهد مباريات كره القدم كل يوم
بات الحظر واجب هذه راس المانيه حديثه
كشفت ان مشاهده مباريات كره القدم تمتلك
تاثيرا سلبيا على القلب ونصحت بالتخفيف من
الحماس المبالغه
للدراسه فان مشاهده الاحداث الرياضيه قد
تؤثر على القلب والاوعيه عن طريق رفع
مستويات التوتر العاطفي الاضافه الى زياده
ضغط الدم ومعدل ضربات القلب بشكل ملحوظ
الباحثون لاحظوا ان المشاركين في الدراسه
عنه من ارتفاع ضغط الدم وصلوا الى معدلات
مرتفعه من ضربات القلب والى مستويات خطيره
ايضا خلال مباريات الحاسمه كما بقيت
القراءات عاليه لعده ساعات بعد المباراه
كما تبين ان الاثاره الناتجه عن اللعبه
تؤدي الى زياده مستويات هرمون الاجهاد هذه
النتائج السابقه التي ابهرت ان الضغط
الناجم عن مشاهده وتشجيع فرق كره القدم
اثناء المنافسات الكبيره يمكن ان يكون له
اثار قصيره